In a sense, the job our government got after 9/11 was nearly impossible. They wanted to stop terrorists before they attacked. But how can you find somebody and stop them and lock them up for something before they actually do it, before they blow up a subway car or take down a building or commit a crime?
从某种意义上说，9/11事件后我国政府接手的任务几乎是不可能完成的。他们想在恐怖分子发动袭击前阻止他们。但在一个人真正实施犯罪——在炸毁地铁车厢、摧毁建筑或进行其他犯罪活动之前，你如何找到他、阻止他并将他关押起来呢？
There's a dilemma, then, for the government, particularly if you've got a group of individuals who you've been surveilling for some time who look like the they fit some profile of would-be terrorists, but they're in the country lawfully and they've committed no crime. On what basis do you take them off the street?
于是，政府陷入了两难境地，特别是当你监视了一群人一段时间，他们看起来符合潜在恐怖分子的特征，但他们是合法入境且并未犯罪时。你凭什么把他们抓起来？
This is William Banks, the head of the Institute for National Security and Counterterrorism at Syracuse University, which did a study looking at the terrorism cases that the Justice Department has prosecuted since 9/11. And he says that what the government decided to do about this dilemma was simply prosecute people that it found suspicious with any charges that it can make stick. At least it would get them off the street.
这是威廉·班克斯（William Banks），雪城大学国家安全与反恐研究所的负责人，该机构曾对司法部自9/11以来起诉的恐怖主义案件进行过研究。他说，政府应对这一困境的做法非常简单：用任何能定罪的罪名去起诉那些被认为可疑的人。至少这样能先把他们抓起来。
And that meant arresting, detaining, for a variety of different reasons-- what you might call the kitchen-sink approach, throw it all and see what sticks. And that's not very pretty and it's not very efficient.
这意味着为了各种不同的理由进行逮捕和拘留——这或许可以被称为“厨房水槽策略”（kitchen-sink approach），即把所有东西都扔进去，看看哪个能凑效。这看起来并不体面，效率也不高。
Take one of the best known cases, one that you may have heard of, the Lackawanna Six. These are six young American men, Muslims, who lived outside Buffalo in the town of Lackawanna Back before September 11, they went to Pakistan and Afghanistan for religious instruction. In Afghanistan, they were taken to an Al-Qaeda training camp. Osama bin Laden was there, they met him. After 10 days, one of the guys didn't like what he was seeing and hearing and he left early. Three other guys also left early. They came back to the United States.
以最著名的案件之一为例，你们可能听说过“拉卡瓦纳六人组”（Lackawanna Six）。这是六名生活在布法罗郊外拉卡瓦纳镇的年轻美国穆斯林男子。在9月11日之前，他们曾前往巴基斯坦和阿富汗接受宗教指导。在阿富汗，他们被带到一个基地组织训练营。奥萨马·本·拉登当时也在那里，他们见过他。10天后，其中一人因为不喜欢所见所闻提前离开了。其他三人也提前离开了。他们回到了美国。
When they returned, there was an anonymous tip given to the FBI, and FBI began serious surveillance of them. And they were in that classic dilemma that I just described: were they a sleeper cell waiting for instructions from somewhere else to carry out a terrorist attack in the United States, or are they just curious young men who happened to travel and simply made a mistake and come back to resume their lives in Buffalo?
他们回国后，联邦调查局（FBI）接到匿名举报，并开始对他们进行严密监视。他们陷入了我刚才描述的经典困境：他们是一个正在等待外部指令、准备在美国发动恐怖袭击的潜伏小组，还是仅仅是几个好奇的年轻人，碰巧去旅游了一趟，犯了个错，然后回国继续在布法罗的生活？
Dozens of FBI agents had them on 24-hour surveillance and they did nothing illegal. So eventually the authorities just couldn't wait any longer and hauled them in. Attending the terrorist camp was material support of terrorism and thus illegal by itself. The men plead guilty, got 8-10 years each. And we still don't know if they were, in fact, a sleeper cell. We don't know if they were terrorists. And this is difficult. Because these cases are all about getting people before they do anything bad, in most of these cases we never find out if the people were really connected to terrorism.
数十名FBI探员对他们进行了24小时监视，但他们没有做任何非法的事。最终，当局等不下去了，把他们抓了起来。参加恐怖分子训练营本身就构成了为恐怖主义提供物质支持，因此是违法的。这几人认罪，每人被判入狱8到10年。我们至今仍不知道他们是否真的是潜伏小组。我们不知道他们是否是恐怖分子。这很难界定。因为这些案件的核心都是在人们做出坏事之前将其抓获，在大多数此类案件中，我们永远无法确定这些人是否真的与恐怖主义有联系。
Today on our radio program, we have the story of another one of the biggest cases that the Justice Department's had on the War on Terror, one of the few that's actually gone to trial. Again, they went after a guy who had not done anything wrong, and they convicted him. On WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. This story takes place in the world of international illegal arms sales and the world of wiretaps and informants and prosecutors. You'll be hearing FBI surveillance tape, you'll hear from the man who got put away, and you'll hear from the U.S. attorney who led the team that put him away. Petra Bartosiewicz has the story, which we're devoting our whole show to today.
今天我们的广播节目将讲述司法部在“反恐战争”中处理的另一大案件，这是少数真正进入审判程序的案件之一。同样，他们针对的是一个并未犯错的人，并且让他被定罪了。这里是WBEZ芝加哥电台，节目是《这美国生活》（This American Life），由公共广播国际公司（PRI）发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。这个故事发生在国际非法武器交易、窃听、线人和检察官的世界里。你们将听到FBI的监视录音，听到那个被关进去的人的声音，以及领导逮捕他的美国联邦检察官的声音。佩特拉·巴托谢维奇（Petra Bartosiewicz）带来了这个故事，我们今天的整个节目都将专注于此。
What you're about to hear is a victory speech almost four years in the making. It's April 23 of this year and the US Attorney is giving a press conference on the steps of the federal courthouse in Newark announcing the conviction of Hemant Lakhani.
你们接下来要听到的是一场酝酿了近四年的胜利演讲。时间是今年的4月23日，美国联邦检察官正在纽瓦克联邦法院的台阶上举行新闻发布会，宣布赫曼特·拉卡尼（Hemant Lakhani）被定罪。
Good morning. My name is Christopher Christie, I'm the United States Attorney for the District of New Jersey. The jury has spoken, and Hemant Lakhani is not a women's clothing salesman. He's been found guilty on all counts for attempting to lend material support to terrorists, money laundering, smuggling, illegal brokering of weapons. Today is a triumph for the Justice Department and the war against terror. I don't know that anyone can say that the state of New Jersey and this country is not a safer place without Hemant Lakhani trotting around the globe attempting to broker arms deals.
早上好。我叫克里斯托弗·克里斯蒂（Christopher Christie），是新泽西州地区的美国联邦检察官。陪审团已经做出了裁决，赫曼特·拉卡尼并不是一名女装推销员。他因试图向恐怖分子提供物质支持、洗钱、走私和非法武器中介等所有罪名被判有罪。今天是司法部和反恐战争的胜利。我不知道是否有人能说，如果没有赫曼特·拉卡尼在全球范围内四处奔波试图促成军火交易，新泽西州乃至整个国家就不会是一个更安全的地方。
Later, the very same day, in the Passaic County lockup sits the convicted terrorist sympathizer Hemant Lakhani.
当天晚些时候，被定罪的恐怖分子同情者赫曼特·拉卡尼坐在帕塞伊克县（Passaic County）的拘留所里。
(CRYING).
（哭泣声）。
Oh, I'm sorry.
噢，我很抱歉。
Hemant Lakhani is a liar, a shameless braggart, a snob. He's amoral, selfish, and he's greedy. But the thing is, if you hear his story, it's hard to believe that on his own he would have ever succeeded in buying or delivering a missile to a terrorist group. In fact, he's an amazingly incompetent illegal arms trader. And it's not at all clear that the world or New Jersey are any safer with him off the streets.
赫曼特·拉卡尼是个骗子，是个厚颜无耻的吹牛大王，是个势利眼。他没有道德，自私且贪婪。但问题是，如果你听了他的故事，很难相信他独自一人就能成功买到或向恐怖组织交付导弹。事实上，他是一个极其无能的非法军火商。而且，让他在街头消失，这个世界或新泽西州是否变得更安全了，这一点完全不明确。
How is Mrs. Lakhani?
拉卡尼夫人怎么样了？
She's OK, I'm going to talk to her later.
她还好，我稍后会和她谈谈。
That's me comforting him, telling him I'm sorry, that his wife is going to be OK. The truth is, I'm not sure I'm exactly sorry, and I don't really know if his wife is going to be OK. But when an old man is sitting next to you crying like that reminiscing about their life together, what else are you going to say?
那是我在安慰他，告诉他我很抱歉，他的妻子会没事的。事实是，我不确定我是否真的感到抱歉，我也不知道他的妻子是否真的会没事。但当一个老人坐在你身边哭泣，回忆着他们在一起的生活时，你还能说什么呢？
By putting me away for 100 years or 5 years or 50 years, what do you think they're doing? Do you think that terrorism is going to stop? I have nothing to do with terrorism. I'm not Muslim, I'm not a part of Al-Qaeda or Hamas or Hamas anything. And what am I going to get from America? What have I got against America? Why?
把我关进监狱100年、5年或50年，你认为他们到底在做什么？你认为恐怖主义会停止吗？我和恐怖主义毫无关系。我不是穆斯林，我不是基地组织或哈马斯的一部分。我能从美国得到什么？我对美国有什么怨恨？为什么？
Hemant Lakhani is 70-years-old. He is Indian, but he's a British citizen who lived in London for decades. And all his life, he's made his living by being a salesman of one sort or another. Clothing, rice, oil, armored personnel carriers-- more on that later-- and lately, it seems, an illegal shoulder-fired missile. So how did a salesman, a guy with no criminal history whatsoever, become a target in the War on Terror? Bad timing has a lot to do with it. As it happened, the US Attorney who sent him to prison, Christopher Christie, was nominated to his job by President Bush on September 10, 2001. His office has this huge conference room with giant windows facing lower Manhattan.
赫曼特·拉卡尼今年70岁。他是印度裔，但他是英国公民，在伦敦住了几十年。他一生都靠做各种推销员为生。卖服装、大米、石油、装甲运兵车——稍后会详谈——最近似乎还涉足非法肩扛式导弹交易。那么，一个没有犯罪记录的推销员，是如何成为“反恐战争”目标的呢？时机不佳是主要原因。碰巧的是，将他送进监狱的美国联邦检察官克里斯托弗·克里斯蒂，是在2001年9月10日被布什总统提名的。他的办公室有一个巨大的会议室，窗户正对着曼哈顿下城。
We're sitting in my conference room doing this interview, you look out those windows, you have an unobstructed view of of Manhattan. And people sat in this conference room and watched both buildings collapse. And so the atmosphere when I came in a few months later after my confirmation was still one of real crisis and of real sadness, and it was enormously stressful.
我们当时坐在会议室里做这次采访，看向窗外，曼哈顿一览无余。当时有人坐在会议室里目睹了两座大楼的倒塌。所以几个月后我上任时，气氛依然笼罩在真正的危机和悲伤中，压力非常巨大。
And I can tell you that in my first six months here, I was confronted on a weekly basis with a widow or a child who had lost their family. In my own parish at home we lost two people. In my children's school, there were three parents who were killed. And they look to you now-- you're the US Attorney-- and they look to you to say, are we safe? And so that was the atmosphere when you walked in, and that was the atmosphere under which Lakhani started. You have to place everything that happens in the early parts of Lakhani in that context, that we were intent, as prosecutors-- and I believe the agents felt this way, too-- of making sure it wasn't going to happen again.
我可以告诉你，我在那里的头六个月里，每周都会面对失去家人的遗孀或孩子。在我家乡的教区，我们失去了两个人。在我孩子就读的学校里，有三位家长的父母去世了。他们现在仰仗着你——你是联邦检察官——他们看着你问：“我们安全吗？”这就是我刚到任时的氛围，也是拉卡尼案件开始时的氛围。你必须把拉卡尼案早期发生的一切置于这个背景下看待，即作为检察官，我们决心——我相信探员们也有同感——确保这种情况不会再次发生。
We clearly now had a brand new mandate from the President and the Attorney General. And the mandate was prevent a terrorist attack, not solve it after it happens, but prevent it. And I don't think people still understand what a sea change that was for federal law enforcement in this country.
我们显然已经收到了总统和司法部长颁布的全新指令。指令就是：预防恐怖袭击，而不是在袭击发生后才去处理，而是要预防它。我不认为人们现在还能理解这对我国的联邦执法来说是多么大的转变。
So it's understandable that Christie's interest was piqued when he heard a report from an informant about Hemant Lakhani his very first week on the job.
因此，当克里斯蒂在入职第一周听到关于赫曼特·拉卡尼的线人报告时，他对该案产生兴趣也就不足为奇了。
It was in a normal weekly terrorism briefing on the fact that we had this informant who was telling us that there was someone who approached him regarding his willingness to broker missile sales.
那是在一次每周例行的恐怖主义简报会上，线人告诉我们，有人曾找过他，询问他是否愿意协助促成导弹交易。
That informant is the next important piece of this story. To explain his part in it, we actually have to go back a couple decades to Lahore, Pakistan, to an American Drug Enforcement Administration agent named Charles Lee. Lee was a former seminarian who, sitting on the toilet one day at school, happened to pick up a Reader's Digest and opened it to a New York cop story called "Merchants of Heroin". He was so taken with the story that he quit the seminary the very next day and became a federal agent. He ended up stationed in Lahore. One day, a contact brought this guy to his office named Habib, who said he wanted to work for the US government on drug cases.
那位线人是这个故事的下一个重要部分。要解释他在其中的角色，我们必须回到几十年前巴基斯坦拉合尔的美国禁毒署（DEA），找一位叫查尔斯·李（Charles Lee）的探员。李曾是一名神学院学生，有一天在学校上厕所时，随手拿起一本《读者文摘》，翻到了一篇讲述纽约警察故事的文章，标题叫《海洛因商人》。他被这个故事深深吸引，第二天就退学成了联邦探员。他最终被派驻拉合尔。有一天，一个联络人把一个叫哈比卜（Habib）的人带到他的办公室，说他想为美国政府处理毒品案件。
He talked about some people that we were quite interested in. I asked him about a particular individual up in Northwest Frontier that we had had no success with. He was wanted in, I believe, at least two or three judicial districts. And he was already indicted, all we needed to do is get him out, but you couldn't even get the Army to go after these people up there. So Habib said that he could get this person out. I thought, well, nothing could be a better acid test than to try that with Habib to begin with, because if he could do that, he must be able to do just about anything. And here, Habib comes along and in no time flat, delivered this guy right out. Kaboom, we had him. And well, it made a believer out of all of us. This guy obviously could do it. So that started it. So everybody loved Habib then.
他提到了一些我们非常感兴趣的人。我问他关于西北边境省的一个特定人物，我们一直没能抓到他。我记得他在至少两三个司法辖区被通缉。他已经被起诉了，我们要做的就是把他引出来，但你甚至连军队都请不动去对付那些人。所以哈比卜说他能把这人弄出来。我想，没有比用哈比卜来做这个“酸性测试”更好的了，如果他能做到，那他几乎无所不能。结果哈比卜没过多久就真的把那个人弄出来了。砰，我们抓到他了。这让我们所有人都相信了。这个家伙显然能行。故事就这样开始了。所以当时每个人都喜欢哈比卜。
Habib turned out to be a great informant. For about a year and a half, he and lee made case after case. Then one day, Habib's cover was suddenly blown. A drug dealer tried to kill him, and Lee swooped in to save him. Within 24 hours, Habib and his family were in the US. But now he had no job and no support. So after a while, he tracked down Lee who, by then, had returned to the US and asked him if he could do DEA cases in the States. Lee tried to discourage him, telling him he'd done enough. But Habib was persistent and they started working together again.
哈比卜后来成了一个出色的线人。在大约一年半的时间里，他和李破获了一起又一起案件。但有一天，哈比卜的卧底身份突然暴露了。一名毒贩试图杀他，李冲进去救了他。24小时内，哈比卜及其家人就到了美国。但现在他没有工作，也没有支持。所以过了一段时间，他找到了已经回到美国的李，问他能不能在美国继续为DEA工作。李试图劝阻他，说他做得够多了。但哈比卜很坚持，他们又开始合作了。
But Lee says Habib wasn't on top of his game because he wasn't on his native turf, and because he was just plain burned out. And that came to light during one investigation where Habib tried to incriminate a guy who, in Lee's words, was not a doper, period. Lee couldn't figure out what Habib's motive was for setting the guy up.
但李说哈比卜的表现不如从前了，因为他离开了本土环境，而且纯粹是因为心力交瘁。这在一次调查中暴露无遗，当时哈比卜试图陷害一个李口中的“绝对不是毒贩”的人。李无法弄清楚哈比卜陷害那个人的动机是什么。
When that happens, it calls into question this guy's abilities and his veracity and, I mean, it calls everything into question. Asking him about it, he didn't have the answers. And when you don't have the answers in this game, it's good night. So rather than trying to second guess a bunch of that, you just close this guy out. That's the end of him. Unreliable. So Lee dropped Habib and fell out of touch with him, until one day he showed up at his house broke, and once again pleading for Lee's help.
当这种情况发生时，它会让人质疑这个人的能力和诚实度，意思就是，它让一切都受到质疑。问他原因，他也答不上来。在这个圈子里，当你没有答案时，就意味着结束。所以与其去猜测，不如直接切断关系。这就是他的结局。不可靠。于是李放弃了哈比卜并断了联系，直到有一天他破产后出现在他家门口，再次乞求李的帮助。
By this time, Lee had retired. Still, he felt guilty for abandoning Habib, who had risked his life for the government and who he considered a friend. So he went ahead and introduced him to the FBI. He figured Habib might be tapped out on drug cases, but maybe he could do some other kinds of informing, like in terrorism investigations. And at the same time, Lee started a rice importing business with him. He thought it would help get Habib on his feet permanently. But pretty soon, he found out Habib had ripped him off. He'd sold the same shipment twice, and Lee had to make good on $25,000 he'd stolen from a customer. And then he found out Habib had ripped other people off, too, had threatened people, said he could get people killed. Lee was floored. He cut off Habib completely. He also typed up a nine-page letter about what he learned and delivered it to Habib's FBI handler.
这时，李已经退休了。但他对抛弃哈比卜感到内疚，因为哈比卜曾为政府冒过生命危险，他也视其为朋友。所以他还是把哈比卜引荐给了FBI。他想，哈比卜可能处理毒品案不行了，但也许能干点别的，比如恐怖主义调查。与此同时，李和他合伙做起了大米进口生意。他觉得这能帮哈比卜彻底站稳脚跟。但没过多久，他发现哈比卜坑了他。他把同一批货卖了两次，李不得不赔偿了哈比卜从客户那里骗走的2.5万美元。接着他发现哈比卜还坑了其他人，威胁过别人，说他能让人没命。李彻底崩溃了。他彻底断绝了与哈比卜的往来。他还写了一份九页的报告，详细说明了他所了解的情况，并送交给了哈比卜在FBI的联络人。
I mean, if you find out about it, you better end your relationship with him. It's really, at that point, not even a judgment call.
我的意思是，如果你发现了这种情况，最好还是结束你们的关系。在这一点上，这甚至不需要再衡量。
He never heard back from the FBI, but the FBI did, in fact, deactivate Habib sometime after Lee sent his letter. And then, after 9/11, Habib's experience and language skills suddenly made him a hot property, and different FBI Bureaus were fighting over him. He ended up in the Newark Bureau, which is also the jurisdiction of US Attorney Chris Christie. It's Habib who first spotted Hemant Lakhani and brought him to the attention of the FBI. When Lee heard about the case, he was stunned that the FBI was talking to Habib at all.
他从未收到FBI的回复，但事实上，FBI在李寄出信件后不久确实停止了与哈比卜的合作。但在9/11之后，哈比卜的经验和语言能力突然让他成了抢手货，不同的FBI办公室甚至争抢他。他最终到了纽瓦克办公室，也就是美国联邦检察官克里斯·克里斯蒂的管辖区。正是哈比卜发现了赫曼特·拉卡尼，并将其列为FBI的目标。当李听说这个案子时，他很震惊FBI竟然还在与哈比卜接触。
I was surprised. I don't know. It went through my mind, I wonder how they could justify doing that? I wondered if it was a legit case. I'm sure these terrorism cases are exceedingly difficult to make, and exceedingly difficult to break into. And therein lies the temptation to reactivate a guy like Habib. Maybe they took him out and dusted him off and put him back to work.
我当时很惊讶。我不知道。我心想，他们怎么能证明这样做是对的？我怀疑这是否是一起合法的案件。我确定这些恐怖主义案件极难立案，也极难打入内部。而这正是重新启用哈比卜这样的人的诱惑所在。也许他们把他拉出来，拍掉灰尘，又让他回去工作了。
So here's how Habib ended up at the center of one of the biggest post-9/11 terrorism-related cases. Habib knew an Indian gangster named Abdul Kayum, who also knew Lakhani. Just to clear up a confusing thing about the tape you're about to hear, Habib's full name is Mohammed Habib Rehman, and the government refers to him as Rehman. But his nickname is Hajji, a term of respect for a Muslim who has made the Hajj, the pilgrim's trip to Mecca. So other people call him Hajji. Here's US Attorney Chris Christie.
这就是哈比卜最终成为9/11后最大恐怖主义相关案件核心的原因。哈比卜认识一个叫阿卜杜勒·卡尤姆（Abdul Kayum）的印度黑帮成员，此人也认识拉卡尼。为了理清你们即将听到的录音中令人困惑的部分：哈比卜的全名是穆罕默德·哈比卜·雷赫曼（Mohammed Habib Rehman），政府称他为雷赫曼。但他的绰号是“哈吉”（Hajji），这是对完成了前往麦加朝圣的穆斯林的尊称。所以别人都叫他哈吉。这是美国联邦检察官克里斯·克里斯蒂。
The ties that Lakhani was claiming to have to us to the terrorist whose last name was Kayum was one that was of particular interest to us. The fact that Kayum even knew who Lakhani was-- you know, I don't know what a women's clothing salesman is doing being associated well enough with someone like Kayum to wind up having Kayum be able to recommend him to someone like Rehman.
拉卡尼声称与那位姓卡尤姆的恐怖分子有联系，这令我们特别感兴趣。卡尤姆竟然认识拉卡尼——你知道，我不知道一个女装推销员怎么会和卡尤姆这样的人有足够深的交情，以至于让卡尤姆能把他推荐给雷赫曼这样的人。
A word here about Abdul Kayum. He's suspected of a series of bomb attacks in Bombay in 1993. Kayum's name is on terrorist watch lists around the world, and Lakhani's association with him is one of the most incriminating things about this case, and something Lakhani has never been able to explain away. What we do know is that in the fall of 2001, Kayum was sitting in Lakhani's hotel room in Dubai-- a hotel they both regularly stayed at, Lakhani says-- talking business.
关于阿卜杜勒·卡尤姆，在这里插一句。他涉嫌1993年孟买的一系列爆炸袭击。卡尤姆的名字在世界各地的恐怖分子观察名单上，拉卡尼与他的往来是此案最令人怀疑的地方之一，也是拉卡尼一直无法解释清楚的事情。我们所知的是，在2001年秋天，卡尤姆坐在拉卡尼在迪拜的酒店房间里——拉卡尼说他们经常住同一家酒店——谈论生意。
At the time, Lakhani's career was in something of a slump. He had been a successful clothing importer, but when that fell apart in the early 1980s, he went into other stuff. He bought a rice business, and later a small Indian airline. But those went under after a while too. He tried to recoup his losses by brokering various other deals. His latest one was an oil refinery deal. At the moment when he was sitting in the hotel room with Kayum, he was looking for oil investors. At some point, Kayum gets a call on his cell phone from Rehman, aka Hajji, who Kayum knows only as a rich businessman.
当时，拉卡尼的事业处于低谷。他曾是一名成功的服装进口商，但随着80年代初那场生意的崩溃，他转向了其他领域。他买过一家大米公司，后来又买了一家小型印度航空公司。但过了一阵子也都倒闭了。他试图通过促成其他各种交易来挽回损失。他最新的项目是一个炼油厂项目。就在他坐在卡尤姆的酒店房间里时，他正在寻找石油投资者。此时，卡尤姆的手机接到雷赫曼（又名哈吉）的电话，卡尤姆只知道他是个有钱的商人。
So what happened is that Kayum said that Hajji is a very powerful man in America, he's worth, himself, a few hundred million dollars. And maybe he can help you, speak to him. So I said, oh hi, Mr. Hajji, hello. And then he tells me that I believe that you're looking for a financier for a refinery project. So I thought he must be a powerful man.
事情是这样的，卡尤姆说哈吉在美国是一个非常有权势的人，身家有几亿美元。也许他能帮你，你去和他谈谈。所以我说，噢你好，哈吉先生，你好。然后他告诉我，我相信你正在为炼油厂项目寻找融资人。所以我当时觉得他肯定是个大人物。
Of course, he was nothing of the sort. At this point, Rehman was making his living as an FBI informant, and had actually racked up a string of unpaid debts. But Lakhani knew none of this. So Rehman starts to feel Lakhani out to see if he could be of interest to the FBI. He calls him over several months. Henry Klingeman, Lakhani's defense attorney, says at this point, the informant saw Lakhani as his meal ticket.
当然，他根本不是什么大人物。此时，雷赫曼靠做FBI线人为生，其实还背负着一连串未还的债务。但拉卡尼对此一无所知。于是，雷赫曼开始试探拉卡尼，看他是否有价值成为FBI的目标。他联系了拉卡尼几个月。拉卡尼的辩护律师亨利·克林格曼（Henry Klingeman）说，在这一阶段，线人把拉卡尼看作他的“饭票”。
A meal ticket, dupe, patsy. Rehman is everything Lakhani's not. He's smart, he's savvy.
饭票、傻瓜、替罪羊。雷赫曼与拉卡尼截然不同。他聪明、机灵。
When Rehman reports back to the FBI, the information looks incredibly promising. He describes Lakhani as a major weapons trafficker to terrorist groups in at least five countries. Again, Henry Klingeman.
当雷赫曼向FBI汇报时，信息看起来极其诱人。他描述拉卡尼是至少五个国家恐怖组织的军火大亨。还是亨利·克林格曼提到的。
I'm looking at a set of handwritten notes prepared by the FBI agent who handled the informant. The notes are dated December 19, 2001, and they include his summary of what the informant said to him about Lakhani, specifically that Lakhani was a main weapons trafficker tied to Pakistani, Indian criminals, Sri Lankan terrorists, Nepal and United Arab Emirates terrorists, that Lakhani is a broker of crude oil from Iraq-- and again, this was during the time of the embargo. Saddam Hussein was still in power and Iraqi oil was embargoed.
我正在查看FBI处理线人的探员准备的一份手写笔记。笔记日期是2001年12月19日，内容包括他总结的线人关于拉卡尼的信息，特别是拉卡尼是与巴基斯坦、印度罪犯、斯里兰卡恐怖分子、尼泊尔和阿联酋恐怖分子有联系的主要军火商，拉卡尼是伊拉克原油的中介——同样，这发生在禁运期间。当时萨达姆·侯赛因还在位，伊拉克石油处于禁运中。
That Lakhani was supplying weapons to the Mojahedin, the holy warriors in Kashmir, that he was best friends with the Ukrainian Prime Minister-- no name given-- and that he was worth $300 to $400 million, meaning Lakhani. Lakhani, who lives in a semi-detached London home in a London suburb. Two old cars in the garage. With respect to what weapons Lakhani claimed he could sell, the agent's notes indicate that the informant told the agents that Lakhani could sell large-scale weapons, including missiles, anti-aircraft guns, any type of weapons.
拉卡尼向克什米尔的圣战者提供武器，他是乌克兰总理（未提及名字）的挚友，他身家3亿到4亿美元，是指拉卡尼。而拉卡尼本人住在一栋伦敦郊区的半独立式住宅里，车库里只有两辆旧车。关于拉卡尼声称能出售的武器，探员笔记指出，线人告诉探员，拉卡尼能出售大规模武器，包括导弹、高射炮，任何种类的武器。
On January 17, 2002, Lakhani and Rehman finally meet for the first time in Newark. Now the investigation kicks into gear. The government surveillance tapes are rolling. They show grainy black and white images of Lakhani sitting across a large table from Rehman. They're in a room at the Gateway Hilton overlooking Newark Airport, and clearly Rehman is now trying to initiate a deal with Lakhani. And just as clearly, Lakhani is eager to oblige. The two men speak in Urdu and Hindi, and the translation sounds sort of like English-language instructional videos. Rehman's translator is the first voice you'll hear.
2002年1月17日，拉卡尼和雷赫曼终于在纽瓦克第一次见面。现在调查正式启动了。政府的监视录像开始录制。录像显示，拉卡尼坐在雷赫曼对面，在长桌边，图像是粗糙的黑白画面。他们在纽瓦克机场俯瞰的门户希尔顿酒店的一个房间里，显然雷赫曼现在试图诱导拉卡尼进行交易。同样显然的是，拉卡尼很乐意效劳。两人用乌尔都语和印地语交谈，翻译听起来有点像英语语言教学视频。雷赫曼的翻译是你们听到的第一个声音。
Actually, the main thing is--
其实，主要的事情是——
You mean the guns for fighting?
你是说用于战斗的枪支吗？
Yes, the guns, and the anti-aircraft guns.
是的，枪支，还有高射炮。
Yes, they're available.
是的，有货。
Do you have something latest, latest missiles, something sinister, just like Stinger with an effective range of at least 15,000 feet?
你有最新的吗？最新的导弹，那种险恶的东西，就像毒刺那样，有效射程至少1.5万英尺的？
Yes, available.
是的，有货。
Give me the details about that one.
给我那个的详细资料。
The main thing is the anti-aircraft gun.
主要的东西是高射炮。
Yes, the anti-aircraft gun and anything else you think is important. Ammo?
是的，高射炮和其他你认为重要的东西。弹药呢？
In ammo, I can give you whatever you want. Anything you ask for, every gun and everything, as much as you want.
弹药的话，你要多少我都给。只要你开口，每一种枪和所有东西，你要多少有多少。
Do these people also have submarines?
这些人也有潜艇吗？
Yes, they're expert in this.
是的，他们是这方面的专家。
Good.
好。
I mean, this is a guy who promised to sell submarines to the informant if the informant wanted them. That's the kind of thing that ought to make an FBI agent listening to the conversation just take his headphones off and shake his head. Why are we doing this? This guy is promising to sell submarines. It's preposterous. I mean, the one thing he didn't offer was an aircraft carrier or a space shuttle. But if he had asked them for one, I'm sure he could tell you that Lakhani could get you both. Lakhani supposedly told the informant that he-- meaning Lakhani-- has people in the US government. And next to that, it says, obtains weapons, NVG-- which, as we've said, is night vision goggles-- so the obvious implication is that Lakhani has contacts within our own government from whom he obtains weapons, including night vision goggles.
我的意思是，这是一个如果线人想要，他就承诺卖给线人的家伙。这就是那种会让听着录音的FBI探员摘下耳机摇头的事情。我们为什么要做这个？这家伙承诺卖潜艇。这太荒谬了。我是说，他唯一没提供的是航空母舰或航天飞机。但如果他开口要，我相信他也能说拉卡尼两样都能弄到。拉卡尼据称告诉线人他——指的是拉卡尼——在美国政府里有人。在旁边，还有一行字写着：获取武器，夜视仪——正如我们所说的，就是夜视眼镜——所以显而易见的暗示是，拉卡尼在我们政府内部有联系人，能从那里获得武器，包括夜视仪。
And also get me order for night vision goggles.
顺便帮我也弄点夜视仪的订单。
What is that?
那是什么？
That's something for seeing at night.
那是夜间观察用的东西。
Are they buying it?
他们在买这个吗？
Yes, they need a lot of them. It is their demand.
是的，他们需要很多。这是他们的需求。
What, sunglasses?
什么，墨镜？
And it's just evident that he has no idea what this guy is talking about. And they had a similar conversation about plutonium. Supposedly, Lakhani bragged to the informant that he could get plutonium in 22-pound bottles. Now, how he came up with an increment, one can only imagine. But in any event, the informant mentions PLU 135, which is plutonium. And again, Lakhani betrays an absolute ignorance about what this guy is talking about.
很明显他根本不知道这家伙在说什么。他们关于钚有过类似的对话。拉卡尼据称向线人吹嘘他能搞到22磅瓶装的钚。至于他是怎么想出这个计量单位的，只能凭想象了。但无论如何，线人提到了PLU 135，也就是钚。而拉卡尼再次露出了对对方所谈内容完全无知的马脚。
None of the claims that Rehman initially made about the Lakhani checked out, not one of them. Not the supposed arms deals or the nuclear material or the personal wealth. Though it's very possible that the source of this bad information was Lakhani himself. Klingeman describes his client as a name dropper who associated himself with real events and real people, but actually had nothing to do with them. To be sure, his bragging is boundless. Here's a small sample, taken, mind you, from just one conversation.
雷赫曼最初关于拉卡尼的说法，一个都没对上，一个都没有。无论是所谓的军火交易、核材料还是个人财富，都不属实。尽管这些虚假信息的来源极有可能是拉卡尼本人。克林格曼将他的客户形容为一名喜欢攀附权贵的人，他将自己与真实的事件和真实的人联系在一起，但实际上与他们毫无关系。当然，他的吹牛是无边无际的。这是一个小样本，记住，仅仅来自一次谈话。
The richest man in London as an Indian is concerned, I was the richest man. This was Lakhani in those days. And when I used to get done at the airport, there was a red carpet for Lakhani. Red carpet. Nothing, not blue or green, a red carpet was given to me. Why? Because I was the most important man. I became very friendly with the Royal Family, and it's a fact. And they used to love me. [UNINTELLIGIBLE] is the [UNINTELLIGIBLE], you know that. I know him very well, believe me.
作为印度人，我是伦敦最富有的人。那时候的拉卡尼就是这样。当我从机场出来时，有一条红地毯是为拉卡尼铺的。红地毯。不是蓝色也不是绿色，是红地毯。为什么？因为我是最重要的人。我和王室变得非常友好，这是事实。[听不清]是[听不清]，你知道的。我非常了解他，相信我。
He claimed to have lunch with Tony Blair at 10 Downing Street. Said he knew Libyan dictator Muammar Gaddafi, former Pakistani Prime Minister Benazir Bhutto, the Prime Minister of Sri Lanka, the President of Congo. When I first visited him in prison, I asked him if he really knew all these people. He told me, you want to meet Tony Blair? Give me 48 hours and he'll be in your house.
他声称和托尼·布莱尔在唐宁街10号共进午餐。说他认识利比亚独裁者穆阿迈尔·卡扎菲、巴基斯坦前总理贝娜齐尔·布托、斯里兰卡总理、刚果总统。我第一次在监狱探访他时，问他是否真的认识所有人。他告诉我：“你想见托尼·布莱尔吗？给我48小时，他就会出现在你家。”
So it's quite possible that Lakhani lied to Rehman about who he was, or maybe Rehman exaggerated. Understandably, this isn't something the government wants to contemplate. Here's US Attorney Chris Christie.
所以极有可能是拉卡尼对雷赫曼撒了谎，或者雷赫曼夸大了事实。可以理解，这不是政府愿意深入探讨的事情。这是美国联邦检察官克里斯·克里斯蒂。
Did you ever feel at any point in the investigation that he oversold Lakhani even a little bit on some of those things that didn't seem to pan out, like his $300 to $400 million net worth, that he was a major arms trafficker in numerous countries?
在调查过程中的任何时候，你是否觉得他稍微有点夸大拉卡尼的价值，比如关于他3-4亿美元的净资产，或者说他是多个国家的军火大亨？
You know, listen. I'm not going to sit around and second guess it. What was done was done, and I think ultimately the jury decided that question.
你知道，听着。我不会坐在这里去质疑它。做过的事情已经做了，我认为最终陪审团回答了那个问题。
For Christie, it was enough that Lakhani knew Kayum, and that he had done at least one arms deal before he met the informant. That was enough experience in the arms trade to be suspicious.
对克里斯蒂来说，拉卡尼认识卡尤姆，且在见到线人之前至少做过一次军火交易，这已经足够了。这足以成为怀疑的理由。
Like if you came to me today, Petra, and said to me, Chris, give me a brochure on the Stinger missile and see if you could fax it to me. Just because I'm doing this program, and if you could get it for me. I wouldn't know the first place to start. Where do I get a brochure on Stinger missile or on an Igla missile. I would have no idea where to start. I don't know if you'd have an idea of where to start. Lakhani knew.
比如你今天来找我，佩特拉，对我说：“克里斯，给我一份毒刺导弹的宣传册，看看能不能传真给我。”仅仅因为我在做这个项目。我就不知道从哪儿开始。我去哪儿弄毒刺导弹或伊格拉导弹的宣传册？我根本不知道从哪儿下手。我不知道你是否知道从哪儿下手。但拉卡尼知道。
Actually, if you Google the word Stinger, missile, and brochure, you can find a Stinger sales brochure in a few seconds. And the one arms deal the government knew Lakhani was part of went like this. As an assistant to another broker, Lakhani had helped arrange the sale of some armored personnel carriers to Angola for use by the President of Angola. Proper paperwork was filed with various governments. Everything was above board. It was all perfectly legal. If you push Christie, he'll admit that at the end of the day, Lakhani wasn't exactly a criminal mastermind or even a very good salesman, but he was the suspect they had. They couldn't predict where the next attack on America might come from, so they'd investigate Lakhani as aggressively as possible to see where he might lead them and who he might lead them to.
事实上，如果你在谷歌搜索“毒刺、导弹、宣传册”，几秒钟就能找到。而政府知道拉卡尼参与的那唯一一次军火交易是这样的：作为另一名中介的助理，拉卡尼曾协助促成了向安哥拉总统出售一些装甲运兵车的交易。各国政府都提交了正规文件。一切都是公开的。这完全合法。如果你逼问克里斯蒂，他会承认最终拉卡尼算不上什么犯罪大师，甚至不是个好的推销员，但他确实是他们手里的嫌疑人。他们无法预测对美国的下一次袭击会来自何方，所以他们尽可能激进地调查拉卡尼，看看他会把他们引向哪里，引向什么人。
So they begin to ratchet up the case. The informant Rehman tells Lakhani he wants to order 200 missiles. But first, Lakhani has to prove he can deliver. He needs to get just one, a sample, and he needs to ship it to Newark. There's talk of hundreds of thousands in profits and a half million dollar bonus. Then Rehman tells Lakhani that he represents a Somali terrorist group called the Ogaden Liberation Front-- a real organization, by the way, but not a terrorist one. And at a certain point well into the deal, Rehman tells the group wants to start Jihad in America, and throws in a reference to Al-Qaeda for good measure. Lakhani, usually talkative on any subject, seems to have no reaction to this news. "Boss, you have no idea how much money there is in this business", Rehman says.
于是他们开始加大案件力度。线人雷赫曼告诉拉卡尼他想订购200枚导弹。但首先，拉卡尼必须证明他能交付。他只需要弄到一个样品，运到纽瓦克。谈话中提到了数十万美元的利润和五十万美元的奖金。然后雷赫曼告诉拉卡尼，他代表一个叫欧加登解放阵线的索马里恐怖组织——顺便说一下，这是一个真实的组织，但不是恐怖组织。在交易进行到一定阶段，雷赫曼告诉他该组织想在美国发动“圣战”，并顺便提到了基地组织。拉卡尼平日里对任何话题都侃侃而谈，对这个消息却似乎毫无反应。“老板，你不知道这生意里有多少钱”，雷赫曼说。
If you ask Lekhani why he did it, he can't really explain. He says it wasn't ideological or political, and he claims he didn't need the money. The best answer he came up with when my producer, Sarah Koenig, and I interviewed him was, well, voodoo. And a lot of long distance phone calls.
如果你问拉卡尼为什么这么做，他真的无法解释。他说这不是意识形态或政治原因，并声称他不需要钱。当我的制片人莎拉·科尼格（Sarah Koenig）和我采访他时，他给出的最好答案是：嗯，巫术。还有大量的长途电话。
By the second meeting, you had already agreed to try to get this stuff for him. Why did you do that?
到第二次见面时，你已经同意尝试帮他弄到这些东西了。你为什么要那样做？
Well, I told you it was a mistake.
嗯，我告诉过你了，这是一个错误。
To say it's a mistake, it seems to be understating the activity. It's more than a mistake. It's a serious decision to enter into something that's potentially--
说是错误，这似乎低估了你的行为。这不仅仅是个错误。这是一个进入某种潜在危险行为的严肃决定——
You're interrupting me.
你打断我了。
It's a legitimate question. There's a guy who you have some doubts about, he's asking you for things that you know are illegal, basically. You have other priorities with your oil deal, you're trying to get financing, why do you bother to go forward with this guy?
这是一个合法的问题。有一个你对他有些怀疑的人，在向你要一些你知道本质上是非法的东西。你的石油生意还有其他优先事项，你正试图获得融资，为什么还要继续和这个家伙纠缠？
Well, it happened. He induced me. You can call it inducing. He induced me, that's all I can tell you. I have no other reply.
嗯，事情就是这样发生的。是他引诱我的。你可以称之为引诱。是他引诱我，我只能告诉你这些。我没有别的回答。
What does that mean, exactly, to you, though? How did he get to you? You are very worldy, you know many people, you've done these deals before, how is that he is able to convince you?
对你来说，这到底意味着什么？他是怎么搞定你的？你阅历丰富，认识很多人，以前也做过这些交易，他是怎么让你信服的？
He induced me, that's all I can tell you. He induced me. Nothing more. I was not greedy, I was not looking for extra money or big money or small money, because money isn't an object in my life. But he induced me. Somehow he made some kind of magic on me and I could say no. Whatever happened, I don't know. And he used to bother me like nobody's business. He would bother me 10 times a day. Sometimes-- I can show you the transcript-- call number one, call number two, call number three, call number four, call number five. 10:05, 5:11, 5:20. 300 telephone calls he has made. What about these, what about that?
是他引诱我，我只能告诉你这些。是他引诱我。没别的了。我不贪婪，我不需要额外的钱，大钱小钱都不需要，因为钱在我的生活中不是主要目标。但他引诱我。不知何故，他对我施了魔法，我拒绝不了。发生了什么我不知道。他就像烦人精一样骚扰我。他一天会烦我10次。有时候——我可以给你看文字记录——第一个电话、第二个、第三个、第四个、第五个。10:05，5:11，5:20。他打了300个电话。这个怎么办，那个怎么办？
He just annoyed you into it?
他只是用烦人的手段让你不得不答应？
Not annoyed, but he would not leave me alone.
不是烦人，但他就是不肯放过我。
Did you ever get suspicious that he was so persistent?
你有没有怀疑过他为什么这么坚持？
Yes.
有。
Did you want him to like you?
你想让他喜欢你吗？
Well, I don't think anybody who dislikes me in my life. Nobody has disliked me.
嗯，我不觉得生命中有人会讨厌我。没人讨厌我。
Klingeman, his attorney, says Lakhani didn't seem at all bothered by the phone calls and attention. In fact, he says, his reaction was just the opposite. Fundamentally, what drove him was a desire to be part of something. He had failed in business and, to a great extent, he had failed in life. He's an old man. And this was his chance to be part of something. He enjoyed the flattery and the attention of the informant and he enjoyed the phone calls, he enjoyed the globetrotting, and I think that more than anything else is what drove him.
他的律师克林格曼说，拉卡尼似乎完全没有被这些电话和关注打扰。事实上，他说，他的反应恰恰相反。从根本上说，驱动他的是一种参与到某件事中的渴望。他在商业上失败了，很大程度上，他在生活中也失败了。他是个老人。这是他参与到某件事中的机会。他享受线人的奉承和关注，他享受那些电话，他享受环游世界的感觉，我认为这比其他任何事情都更驱动他。
Here was someone coming to Mr. Lakhani, a sad sack, Willy Loman of a character and saying, you're a big boss, you're a big man, you have connections. Help me. And Mr. Lakhani has never heard this from anyone before.
这里有人来找拉卡尼先生，一个像威利·洛曼（Willy Loman）一样的失意角色，对他说是：你是大老板，你是大人物，你有关系。帮帮我。拉卡尼先生以前从未从任何人那里听到过这些。
But was Lakhani just a sad sack? It's true, a lot of the business deals Lakhani bragged about seem like complete fabrications. But some of them were real. And his wife, Kusum, showed me photos proving that he moved in some pretty fancy circles.
但拉卡尼真的只是个失意者吗？确实，拉卡尼吹嘘的很多生意看起来像是编造的。但其中一些是真的。他的妻子库苏姆（Kusum）给我看了照片，证明他确实出入于一些相当高端的圈子。
This is a photo of prince of Abu Dhabi who came to play polo with Prince Charles, and we visited the grounds. Prince Charles is shaking hands with my husband, and I am standing by on the side.
这是阿布扎比王子的照片，他来和查尔斯王子打马球，我们参观了场地。查尔斯王子在和我丈夫握手，我就站在旁边。
But then again, there are so many odd moments in the FBI tapes, moments where Lakhani just seems out of his element. One minute he'd be talking about weapons systems, the next he'd be offering a diamond deal or scrap metal, anything. Here's an exchange where Lakhani is weirdly candid about what he thought his first meeting with Rehman was going to be about. Lakhani is speaking first here.
但话说回来，FBI录音中确实有很多奇怪的时刻，拉卡尼看起来完全不在状态。这一分钟他还在谈论武器系统，下一分钟他可能就在推销钻石交易或废金属，什么都行。这是其中一段交流，拉卡尼对于他认为自己和雷赫曼第一次见面应该讨论的内容显得出奇地坦诚。拉卡尼先开口。
When you first met me, did you have any idea that you will be doing this? How did this happen?
你第一次见我时，你有没有想到你会做这个？这是怎么发生的？
Yes, I was looking for a serious person. After meeting with you, I felt that this could also be done.
是的，我在找一个认真的人。见到你之后，我觉得这事也能办成。
OK, to be honest, my idea was this: you told me there are so many Mexican people and they eat a lot of mangoes. Do you remember the mangoes from India? It was my idea to import mangoes from India. I'm telling the truth.
好吧，老实说，我的想法是这样的：你告诉过我有很多墨西哥人，他们吃很多芒果。你记得印度的芒果吗？我当时的想法是从印度进口芒果。我说的都是真的。
Mangoes. And then, without missing a beat, Lakhani goes right back to discussing weapons. Then there's this exchange about Indian sweets. To me, he seems like an insecure man here, desperate to please. Again, Lakhani speaks first and he mentions Kusum, his wife.
芒果。然后，拉卡尼毫无停顿地又回到了讨论武器上。接着是这段关于印度甜点的对话。对我来说，他在这里看起来像个缺乏安全感、急于讨好的人。还是拉卡尼先开口，他提到了他的妻子库苏姆。
Eat the sweets I brought for you, they are very high class. Try this one.
吃点我给你带来的甜点，这是很高档的。尝尝这个。
Wow.
哇。
Is it your favorite one?
这是你最喜欢的吗？
Yes, I like it very much.
是的，我很喜欢。
Yes, it is balushahi.
是的，这是巴鲁沙希（balushahi）。
This is my favorite.
这是我最喜欢的。
Kusum told me you would like it.
库苏姆告诉过我你会喜欢的。
Yes, I like it most.
是的，我最喜欢了。
Believe me, Kusum said you would like balushahi.
相信我，库苏姆说你会喜欢巴鲁沙希的。
Yes.
是的。
She was saying this sweet is very good, even I did not know it.
她说这种甜点很好吃，连我自己都不知道。
Really, it is very delicious.
真的，非常美味。
Kusum was saying so. I will call her right now and tell her that you like balushahi.
库苏姆说是这样的。我现在就打电话告诉她你喜欢巴鲁沙希。
Haha, that's what I told you.
哈哈，我早跟你说了。
So she was right.
所以她是正确的。
Will you eat some?
你要吃点吗？
Yes, definitely. Kusum was saying you will like it. Is it true?
是的，当然。库苏姆说你会喜欢的。是真的吗？
Yes.
是的。
Oh, this is very tasty.
噢，这太好吃了。
But ask US Attorney Chris Christie about it, and it turns out he reads the scene completely differently.
但如果你问美国联邦检察官克里斯·克里斯蒂，结果他完全是以另一种方式解读这个场景。
I absolutely agree with your description of him in that way, but I take something completely different from it. I don't think that he's this inane guy, which is what I'm getting from you. This is an idiot sitting there talking about the sweets he got and why doesn't he get to the missile deal already? But the fact of the matter is Lakhani's trying to be a nice guy, a good guy. He's trying to get on this guy's good side no matter what he has to do to do it because he wants to make the deal.
我完全同意你对他的那种描述，但我得出了完全不同的结论。我不认为他是个愚蠢的家伙——那是我从你那里感受到的观点。这只是一个坐在这里谈论他带来的甜点，还问为什么还不快点谈导弹交易的白痴吗？事实是拉卡尼正试图做一个好人，一个友善的人。他正试图无论如何都要赢得这个人的好感，因为他想促成这笔交易。
This is the conduct of a person who's a salesman. I don't care what you're selling, whether it's a used car, women's clothing, or a missile. The deal is to get a customer who's willing to buy, and who buys from you. And he thinks, this guy could go to somebody else if he gets frustrated with me so I'm going to try to keep him close. And that's the way I view that interaction.
这是一个推销员的行为。我不在乎你在卖什么，不管是二手车、女装还是导弹。目标是找到一个愿意购买的客户，并且从你这里购买。他想，如果这个家伙对我感到沮丧，他可能会找别人，所以我得尝试把他留住。这就是我如何看待那种互动。
Coming up, in the words of the old saying, keep your friends close, keep your shoulder-fired surface-to-air missile closer. Our story about Hemant Lakhani continues in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
稍后，用那句老话来说，亲近你的朋友，亲近你的肩扛式地对空导弹。关于赫曼特·拉卡尼的故事，我们稍后在新泽西芝加哥广播电台和公共广播国际公司的节目中继续。
This is American Life , I'm Ira Glass. Today, we're devoting our whole show to the story of the government prosecution of Hemant Lakhani on terrorism-related charges. For nearly two years, Lakhani spoke with government informant Mohammed Habib Rehman. Again, here's Petra Bartosiewicz.
这里是《这美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天，我们的整个节目专注于政府以恐怖主义相关罪名起诉赫曼特·拉卡尼的故事。近两年来，拉卡尼一直与政府线人穆罕默德·哈比卜·雷赫曼沟通。再次请出佩特拉·巴托谢维奇。
It did seem Lakhani would say anything to please Rehman. Whatever item Rehman requested, anti-aircraft weapons, landmines, radioactive suitcase bombs, his answer was always the same: it is available. Here's Lakhani in the second meeting promising to get Rehman Russian-made Igla missiles, the surface-to-air, shoulder-fired kind.
拉卡尼似乎确实会说任何话来讨好雷赫曼。无论雷赫曼要求什么物品——高射武器、地雷、放射性手提箱炸弹，他的回答总是同一个：有货。这是拉卡尼在第二次见面时，承诺给雷赫曼弄到俄制伊格拉导弹，就是那种肩扛式的地对空导弹。
How many do you want?
你要多少？
About 200.
大约200枚。
It will be done. It will be arranged immediately. I will go there on Sunday. The delivery will be ready on Monday.
没问题。会立即安排。我周日去那里。周一交付就会准备好。
He says this on April 25, 2002, that he'll deliver on Monday. But the truth is Lakhani can't deliver on Monday and he can't deliver for the next year. Lakhani's problem isn't just that he can't deliver the missile, it's that he can't actually acquire one. So even though he's promising Rehman the deal is nearly done, in fact there is no deal. Month after month after month, he puts Rehman off and Rehman, understandably, is getting impatient. Here's Lakhani's attorney, Henry Klingeman, again.
他是在2002年4月25日这么说的，说他会在周一交付。但事实是，拉卡尼周一交不出货，接下来的整整一年他也交不出。拉卡尼的问题不仅是他交不出导弹，而是他根本弄不到。所以尽管他承诺雷赫曼交易即将完成，实际上根本没有交易。一个月接一个月，他一直拖着雷赫曼，而雷赫曼可以理解地变得不耐烦了。这里是拉卡尼的律师亨利·克林格曼。
In terms of the chronology, between January, 2002 and August of 2003, there's a pattern. And there's no point in going conversation by conversation because the conversations are all the same. The informant says, what's happening? Lakhani says the deal is done. The informant says, well, where's the missile? Lakhani says, it'll be here any day. And the missile never shows up and the informant calls back two days later and says, well, what's happening? Lakhani says, the deal is done. The informant says, well, where's the missile? Lakhani says, it will be here any day. And then it just goes on and on and on.
从时间表来看，在2002年1月到2003年8月之间，有一个模式。没必要逐个对话去分析，因为谈话都大同小异。线人说：“进展如何？”拉卡尼说：“交易完成了。”线人说：“那么，导弹在哪儿？”拉卡尼说：“随时会到。”但导弹从没出现，线人两天后再打来电话说：“那么，进展如何？”拉卡尼说：“交易完成了。”线人说：“那么，导弹在哪儿？”拉卡尼说：“随时会到。”事情就是这样没完没了地循环。
Lakhani's one, and possibly only, weapons contact with the Ukrainian state-controlled arms manufacturer, a company called Uker Spitz Export. This was the company that Lakhani got the armored personnel carriers from in the Angola deal. He showed Rehman their weapons brochures, but to buy missiles from them, he'd need special government paperwork, which he didn't have. So he started asking around in some shadier corners of the former Soviet republics. Apparently, he wasn't so subtle about it because soon enough, the FSB, the Russian Security Service, caught wind of it and started tracking Lakhani. Here's Chris Christie.
拉卡尼唯一可能有的军火联系渠道是一家由乌克兰国家控制的武器制造商，叫Uker Spitz Export。这就是拉卡尼在安哥拉交易中获得装甲运兵车的公司。他给雷赫曼看了他们的武器手册，但要从他们那里购买导弹，他需要特殊的政府文件，而他没有。所以他开始在苏联前加盟共和国的一些阴暗角落打听。显然，他打听得不够隐秘，因为很快，俄罗斯安全局（FSB）就察觉到了，并开始追踪拉卡尼。这里是克里斯·克里斯蒂。
At some point, Russian law enforcement-- the FSB contacted the FBI to let them know that they knew Lakhani was contacting legitimate sources in the old Soviet Union in an attempt to buy these missiles. Well, I know at that point for me, the light bulb really went on and I said, this guy's for real. He knew the right people to call.
在某个阶段，俄罗斯执法机构——FSB联系了FBI，让他们知道他们知道拉卡尼正在尝试联系前苏联的合法渠道购买这些导弹。嗯，我知道在那一刻，灯泡真正亮了，我说，这个家伙是认真的。他知道该给谁打电话。
Still, Lakhani couldn't seem to get one. Months passed. The US government had given Lakhani a buyer, but they were getting tired of waiting for him to drum up a seller. If only he'd find a missile, their case could be done. So they get him a missile. They cook up a plan with the Russians. FSB agents posing as arms dealers sell Lakhani a dummy missile, real in every respect except that it had no munitions. Even an expert would have been fooled. Lakhani falls for it. He even watches the missile being loaded onto a ship in Saint Petersburg that he thinks will carry it to the US. What he didn't know is that the American government had spirited the phony missile onto an airplane. They eventually delivered it to Rehman's hotel room in Newark, in full view of the hidden FBI camera. When Lakhani saw it there, he was shocked. Not that it had arrived in New Jersey, but that it was luxuriating in a suite at the Gateway Hilton.
尽管如此，拉卡尼似乎还是弄不到一枚。几个月过去了。美国政府给拉卡尼提供了一个买家，但他们开始厌倦等待他去拉一个卖家。如果他能找到一枚导弹，他们的案件就能结束了。所以他们给他提供了一枚导弹。他们与俄罗斯人策划了一个计划。FSB探员假扮成军火商，卖给拉卡尼一枚“假导弹”，各方面都和真的一样，只是没有弹药。即使是专家也会被骗到。拉卡尼上钩了。他甚至看着导弹在圣彼得堡被装上一艘船，他以为这艘船会把它运到美国。他不知道的是，美国政府已经把这枚假导弹神不知鬼不觉地送上了飞机。他们最终把它送到了雷赫曼在纽瓦克的酒店房间，全程都在隐藏的FBI摄像头拍摄之下。当拉卡尼在房间里看到它时，他很震惊。不是因为它到了新泽西，而是它正大剌剌地放在门户希尔顿的套房里。
What were you expecting when you went to the hotel?
你去酒店时期待看到什么？
I was expecting to discuss everything, that's all. I never thought that the missile would be sitting on the sofa.
我期待讨论一切，就是这样。我从没想过导弹会放在沙发上。
[LAUGHING]
（笑声）
Yeah, that's it. I see the box lying exactly in the middle of the sofa, the big one. Not the two side ones, but the middle one. I said, he is a guest of you? And I'm surprised, I told him, how did it come? He said, Lakhani, I told you. In America you can smuggle anything. So I said, you are a very powerful man, Mr. Hajji. That's what I told him. And then he wanted to open it. I said, no, don't open it because I'm scared because I don't know how to even open. Which is right side or wrong side? I don't know nothing about it.
是的，就是这样。我看到箱子正正好好放在沙发中间，那个大的。不是旁边那两个，是中间那个。我说，他是你的客人吗？我很惊讶，我告诉他，它是怎么来的？他说：“拉卡尼，我告诉过你。在美国你可以走私任何东西。”所以我说：“你真是一个很有权势的人，哈吉先生。”我就是这么对他说的。然后他想打开它。我说：“不，别打开，我很害怕，因为我连怎么打开都不知道。哪边是正面哪边是反面？我对此一无所知。”
Here's the video of that moment. Lakhani speaks first.
这是那一刻的录像。拉卡尼先开口。
That is so wonderful. Allah fulfilled your wish. The stuff arrived here. What a big thing.
这太棒了。真主满足了你的愿望。东西到了。真是件大事。
Please sit down.
请坐。
This box, how it arrive here?
这个箱子，它是怎么到这儿的？
Yes, it is here. Boss, what did I tell you? I told you that you can smuggle anything into America. Didn't I tell you?
是的，在这儿了。老板，我跟你说过什么？我告诉过你，你可以把任何东西走私进美国。我没跟你说过吗？
Yes, the same box.
是的，同一个箱子。
That's right, the same box.
没错，同一个箱子。
Yes, I raise my hands. I can't believe what we have done.
是的，我举起双手。我无法相信我们做到了。
Realizing the deal is almost finished, Lakhani becomes so delighted, he leans over the box holding the missile, puts both his hands over his head, and shakes them around as if he's trying to amuse a newborn baby. A few things seem clear here. First of all, he doesn't know the first thing about how this missile works, not even which end is the shooting end. And it seems obvious he's never done anything like this before. He makes a few illegal weapons sale faux pas even your mother wouldn't make. Earlier the deal, he'd offered to pay for the missile with a personal check. Later, he hand-wrote an IOU for it to a Russian agent using his full name, Hemant Shantalil Lakhani. But here's my favorite. Rehman is first here.
意识到交易即将完成，拉卡尼变得非常高兴，他俯身在装导弹的箱子上，双手抱住头，像是在逗新生儿一样晃动。这里有几件事很明确。首先，他根本不懂这枚导弹是怎么工作的，甚至不知道哪头是发射端。显然他以前从没做过类似的事。他犯了一些连你母亲都不会犯的非法军火交易错误。在交易初期，他提出用个人支票支付导弹费用。后来，他亲手写了一张借条给一名俄罗斯特工，使用了他的全名：赫曼特·尚塔利尔·拉卡尼（Hemant Shantalil Lakhani）。但我最喜欢的是这一段。雷赫曼先开口。
Boss, here is another thing. It has a serial number.
老板，还有一件事。它有一个序列号。
What does it mean?
那是什么意思？
This is the serial number, and we don't need it.
这是序列号，我们不需要它。
Why not?
为什么不？
Because.
因为。
It can be caught.
它会被抓到的。
It can be tracked from the serial number.
它可以通过序列号追踪到。
It is good that you've told me.
你告诉我是对的。
Look here, I have removed it.
你看这儿，我已经把它去掉了。
So you don't need it?
所以你不需要它？
Right.
对。
What's also clear, though, is that Lakhani knows perfectly well what Rehman wants to do with the missile. They've pulled the curtain back from the hotel window and are holding up the missile as they survey the airplanes parked on the tarmac at Newark Airport.
不过也很清楚的是，拉卡尼完全知道雷赫曼想用这枚导弹做什么。他们拉开了酒店窗户的窗帘，把导弹举起来，观察停在纽瓦克机场停机坪上的飞机。
Boss, from here, if four, five, or six planes fall, what will happen?
老板，从这儿，如果四架、五架或六架飞机掉下来，会发生什么？
They will be badly shaken.
它们会受到重创。
What will happen to their economy?
它们的经济会发生什么？
If it happens 10 or 15 places simultaneously at the same time--
如果它同时在10或15个地方发生——
You mean different airports at the same time?
你是说不同的机场同时发生？
The same time is very important. They will think the war has started.
同时是非常重要的。他们会认为战争已经开始了。
So he's putting on my shoulder and he says, look, now from here you can see the airport and we can shoot. And he asks me, how many airports? I said, look, I only know JFK, that's all. I don't know, I've never dealt within America, so I can't tell you anything. He says, no no, 10 airport. And what is the best time? I said, the best time is the busiest time is either on Monday or Friday. That's all I told him. Which is the busiest time, not the best time. Busiest time.
所以他把（导弹）架在我的肩膀上，他说，看，从这里可以看到机场，我们可以射击。他问我，多少个机场？我说，看，我只知道肯尼迪机场，就是这样。我不知道，我从来没在美国进行过交易，所以我不能告诉你任何事情。他说：“不，不，10个机场。”最好的时间是什么时候？我说，最好的时间就是最繁忙的时间，要么是周一要么是周五。我只告诉了他这些。什么是最繁忙的时间，不是最好的时间。最繁忙的时间。
To do what?
做什么？
To shoot.
射击。
Say, Sunday morning at 10 o'clock?
比如周日早上10点？
Like Sunday morning.
就像周日早上。
In the morning, around 10:00 or 10:15 or 10:20 when all are still sleeping or whatever.
在早上，大约10点或10点15或10点20，当所有人都还在睡觉的时候，无论怎样。
What is the busiest day for flights?
航班最繁忙的一天是什么？
Monday.
周一。
Monday?
周一？
Yes, Monday or Friday.
是的，周一或周五。
You've got a missile on your shoulder-- or he does, I don't know.
你肩膀上扛着一枚导弹——或者他扛着，我不确定。
He does.
是他扛着。
He does, OK. And you're looking at airplanes and he's saying, when's the busiest time? And he's talking clearly about shooting down a commercial airplane.
是他扛着，好的。你正看着飞机，他说，“最忙的时间是什么？”他显然是在谈论击落一架民用飞机。
Who started this? September 17, he said that I'm buying this for the purpose of shooting civilian airlines.
谁开始的？9月17日，他说我买这个的目的是为了击落民航客机。
What did you think of this purpose? Did you think that was a good idea?
你觉得这个目的怎么样？你觉得这是个好主意吗？
Not at all. I thought he was joking.
一点也不。我以为他在开玩笑。
Sitting in jail, Lakhani went on to say that he thought the weapons were to be used in Africa in tribal skirmishes in Kenya or Nigeria or wherever, but even his own lawyer told us he didn't buy that one. The tape of this last meeting on August 12, 2003 just peters out. That's because at a certain point, Rehman leaves the room and six federal agents come in and arrest Lakhani. Once he understands the meetings are on tape, he pretty much confesses, saying something like, I'm sorry. You know everything. But even then, Lakhani still didn't quite comprehend what was happening.
坐在监狱里，拉卡尼后来继续说，他以为这些武器是用于肯尼亚或尼日利亚等地的部落冲突中，但连他自己的律师都告诉我们，他不买这个账。8月12日最后一次会议的录音到这里就中断了。因为在某个时刻，雷赫曼离开了房间，六名联邦探员冲进来逮捕了拉卡尼。一旦他明白会议是被录音的，他几乎就承认了，说了类似“我很抱歉，你们知道一切”的话。但即便如此，拉卡尼依然没有完全理解正在发生的事情。
Kusum told me when she visited her husband in jail right after his arrest, he asked her where everyone else was, why Rehman wasn't sharing a cell with him. And that's when she told him. There is no one else. You're it. She said Lakhani was dumbfounded. He'd bought a fake missile from a fake arms dealer and delivered it to a fake terrorist. Every part of the crime had been supplied to him by the US government.
库苏姆告诉我，当她在丈夫被捕后去监狱探访时，他问她其他人都在哪儿，为什么雷赫曼没和他关在一个牢房里。就在那时她告诉了他真相。根本没有其他人。只有你一个。她说拉卡尼当时惊呆了。他从一个假军火商那里买了枚假导弹，交付给了一个假恐怖分子。犯罪的每一个环节都是美国政府提供给他的。
That was almost two years ago. Lakhani's case went to trial in January this year. The only defense available to him was entrapment, that if the government hadn't set him up, he would have never supplied a missile to a terrorist group or anyone else. At trial, the state would have to prove that Lakhani was ready and willing to do the deal, or that he was able to actually get the missile. Lakhani's lawyer told jurors that although he may be loathsome and an idiot, of the requirements, was only willing. Not ready, and certainly not able. Here's Lakhani's lawyer, Henry Klingeman.
那是近两年前的事了。拉卡尼的案件于今年1月开庭审理。他唯一能用的辩护是“诱捕”，即如果政府没有设局，他绝不会向恐怖组织或任何人提供导弹。在审判中，州政府必须证明拉卡尼已经准备好且愿意进行交易，或者证明他有能力真正弄到导弹。拉卡尼的律师告诉陪审团，虽然他可能令人厌恶且是个白痴，但（政府）要求的条件，他只占了“愿意”这一条。并没有“准备好”，更谈不上“有能力”。这是拉卡尼的律师亨利·克林格曼。
The entrapment defense is designed for people who are morally guilty, to be legally not guilty. In terms of a legal defense, this was a great defense on September 10 when cooler heads might have prevailed, because he was clearly entrapped.
诱捕辩护是为那些道德上有罪、但在法律上无罪的人设计的。从法律辩护的角度来看，这在9月10日是一个极好的辩护，当时冷静的头脑可能会占据上风，因为他显然是被诱捕的。
Unfortunately for Lakhani, it was well past September 11, and what jurors saw was a man talking enthusiastically about shooting down airplanes. But the government's best weapon at the trial was the weapon itself. On the first day, FBI agents carried in a wooden box shaped like a coffin and set it down with a thud in front of the jury. Then the prosecutor opened the box and piece by piece it took out the missile, a long, green steel tube. Donna, a bank executive, was one of the jurors. She asked that we not use her last name.
不幸的是，对拉卡尼来说，那是9/11之后很久了，陪审员们看到的是一个充满热情地谈论击落飞机的人。但政府在审判中最好的武器是武器本身。第一天，FBI探员抬着一个像棺材一样的木箱走进来，沉重地放在陪审团面前。然后检察官打开箱子，把导弹一件件拿出来，一根长长的绿色钢管。唐娜（Donna）是一位银行主管，她是陪审员之一。她要求我们不要使用她的姓氏。
I am known as juror number six from the Lakhani trial that took place in Newark, New Jersey. I listened very intently to both sides of the argument and day number one, I hadn't passed judgment. I was just very focused on making sure I took as many notes and not to let my emotions sway. Because as soon as I started to hear the bad things being said about America and Americans-- and I'm very patriotic-- they upset me. When I saw the missile being brought into the courtroom, they took it out and they passed it by the jurors, I cringed. Every time I saw the box, I cringed.
我是拉卡尼案的6号陪审员，案件发生在新泽西州纽瓦克。我非常专注地听取了双方的论点，第一天我没有做出判断。我非常专注于记尽可能多的笔记，不让自己的情绪左右判断。因为当我开始听到关于美国和美国人的坏话时——我非常爱国——他们让我心烦意乱。当我看到导弹被带进法庭，他们拿出来在陪审员面前传阅时，我感到畏缩。每次看到那个箱子，我都感到畏缩。
Donna soon found the evidence overwhelming. So did everybody else. Everybody except one person.
唐娜很快发现证据无可辩驳。其他人也是。除了一个人以外，所有人都这么认为。
My name is Gussie Burnett, I'm 65 years old, I work for Newark Public Schools and I'm a librarian.
我叫格西·伯内特（Gussie Burnett），今年65岁，我在纽瓦克公立学校工作，是一名图书管理员。
Burnett, juror number nine, was the lone holdout.
伯内特，9号陪审员，是唯一的坚持者。
As far as I'm concerned, it was entrapment if he didn't actually do anything.
据我所知，如果他什么都没做，这就是诱捕。
Some of the other jurors seem to think that Lakhani actually could have done this, that he could have gotten that missile if he tried long enough.
其他一些陪审员似乎认为拉卡尼实际上能做到，如果尝试得足够久，他就能弄到那枚导弹。
Did he try for 22 months and then get one, after offering all these millions of dollars and he couldn't get a missile? No, he wasn't gonna never get no missile. And they knew he wasn't gonna get one either, that's why they bought it and set it right there in his lap. From day one, I just can't understand it. They came in and they sit down and they says, this man's guilty, guilty, guilty, guilty, guilty, guilty. They didn't even think about it. Hey, wait a minute. Let's analyze these things, let's do them one by one.
他尝试了22个月才弄到一枚，在出过那么多钱之后还是弄不到导弹？不，他永远也弄不到导弹。他们也知道他弄不到，所以他们才买了它，直接把它放在他腿上。从第一天起，我就无法理解。他们走进来，坐下说：“这人有罪，有罪，有罪，有罪。”他们根本没思考。嘿，等一下。让我们分析这些事情，让我们逐一分析。
For a few hours, Burnett held her ground. It didn't go so well.
伯内特坚持了几个小时。结果并不好。
So I say, he's guilty, someone says, he's not guilty. And I say, he's guilty because look at page 48. And then someone else would say, well look at page 52. So everyone trying to make themselves heard, voices started to rise so you could be heard over the crowd. The juror who felt that he was not guilty I think felt overwhelmed by probably a good six, seven, eight jurors talking loudly at the same time, that actually turned into screaming to be heard. It was probably very intimidating for her.
所以我说，他有罪，有人说，他没罪。我说他有罪，因为看第48页。然后另一个人会说，好吧，看第52页。所以每个人都试图让自己被听到，声音开始变大，为了盖过人群。我认为那个觉得他无罪的陪审员可能被六、七、八个同时大声说话的陪审员压倒了，那些声音最终变成了尖叫。对她来说这可能非常吓人。
Because it was all directed at her.
因为这都是冲着她来的。
Correct, because she was the only one that thought that he was not guilty.
没错，因为她是唯一一个认为他无罪的人。
Pretty soon, Burnett changed her vote.
很快，伯内特改变了投票。
This is how that happened. I just closed on a house in January, and everybody in the jury room knew it because the court was closed down on April 25, so I could go close on the house. So when we came back, I think we started deliberating on a Wednesday. And we got to one count, and I said to the man, not guilty and there ain't nobody gonna change my mind. And the jury foreman said if I didn't go along with them, I wouldn't see the inside of my house until December. So I saw, what the hell. He don't mean nothing to me. This man guilty. But I know it was wrong. It wasn't right for me to do the man like that. It wasn't right. But it's over now.
事情是这样发生的。我刚在一月份买了一套房子，陪审团里的每个人都知道，因为法庭在4月25日关门了，所以我去办房产过户。所以当我们回来时，我想我们是在周三开始审议的。我们进行到一项指控时，我告诉那个人：“无罪，没人能改变我的主意。”陪审团团长说，如果我不随大流，我就得等到十二月才能看到我的房子。所以我心想，去他的。他对我没什么意义。这个人有罪。但我知道这是错的。我那样对待那个人是不对的。这不正确。但现在结束了。
Are you saying you regret your decision to find him guilty?
你是说你后悔你做出他有罪的决定吗？
Yeah. Yeah, I really do. Because as far as I'm concerned, the man was entrapped. I should have held out.
是的。是的，我真的后悔。因为在我看来，那个人是被诱捕的。我当时应该坚持住。
So the only person who bought Lakhani's defense caved in the jury room. It took just over seven hours. The jury found him guilty. In the end, the government spent almost two years and hundreds of thousands of dollars trapping a man who didn't seem to have any connection to any real terrorists or terrorist sympathizers. Chris Christie says it's his main regret about the case, that Lakhani didn't lead them to any other suspects. We asked Christie if maybe the problem wasn't that Lakhani refused to talk but that he simply didn't know anything. I guess it's possible, Christie said. Even so, he's happy with the outcome because it proves that law enforcement is meeting its new mandate.
所以唯一一个接受拉卡尼辩护的人在陪审团室崩溃了。只用了不到七个小时。陪审团判定他有罪。最终，政府花了近两年时间和数十万美元诱捕了一个似乎与任何真正的恐怖分子或恐怖分子同情者毫无关联的人。克里斯·克里斯蒂说，这是他对此案最大的遗憾，就是拉卡尼没把他们引向任何其他嫌疑人。我们问克里斯蒂，问题是不是不在于拉卡尼拒绝开口，而在于他根本什么都不知道。我想是有可能的，克里斯蒂说。即便如此，他对结果很满意，因为它证明执法部门正在履行新的使命。
What Lakhani is emblematic of in the war on terrorism is, in the biggest way, the new American approach to law enforcement in the area of terrorism. We're going to try to catch people before they act.
拉卡尼在反恐战争中的象征意义在于，很大程度上，这是美国在恐怖主义领域的执法新方式。我们将尝试在人们行动之前将其抓获。
But this very policy, as good as it sounds, is what worries people like Henry Klingeman.
但这种政策，听起来虽好，却是像亨利·克林格曼这样的人所担忧的。
You could probably go to the Middle East and collar a random person on the street and ask them what they think of America and ask them what they would do if they were given the ability to send missiles to the United States, and you could probably find millions of people, sadly, who would say, I would do it in a heartbeat. You wouldn't even have to pay me and I would do it. Now, on the government's theory, we'd arrest all those people because they are willing to participate in this type of activity. And we'd say, well, we stopped them before they were able to actually do it. But those people may not be capable of getting involved in Jihad, whoever they are on the streets of Ramallah or the streets of Kabul or wherever.
你大概可以去中东，随便从街上拉一个人，问问他们对美国的看法，问问他们如果能把导弹送到美国他们会怎么做。遗憾的是，你大概能找到数百万人说：“我马上就会做。”你甚至不需要付钱给我，我就会做。现在，根据政府的理论，我们会逮捕所有那些人，因为他们愿意参与此类活动。我们会说，“好吧，我们在他们真正实施之前阻止了他们。”但那些人可能根本没能力参与圣战，无论他们是在拉马拉的街头，还是喀布尔或其他什么地方。
But Mr. Lakhani was not in that position and was not inclined to do this type of thing. He was all too willing to do it when asked, but he was never going to do it until he was asked. And no one was going to ask him, because no real terrorist would ever go to Mr. Lakhani and ask him for anything. So if the government is going to go out and apprehend people before they even think about this stuff, or maybe after they think about it before they ever do anything about it, then we might as well put barbed wire around the entire Middle East, because that's really the logical conclusion on that policy.
但拉卡尼先生并不是处于那种境地，也没有倾向于做这种事。当被要求时，他确实非常愿意去做，但在被要求之前他永远不会做。而没人会要求他做，因为真正的恐怖分子永远不会去拉卡尼先生那里向他要任何东西。所以如果政府打算在人们甚至还没想到这些事情之前就去抓人，或者可能在他们想到之后还没做出任何行动之前就抓人，那么我们还不如在整个中东周围架起铁丝网，因为那才是该政策的逻辑结论。
Ask Christie about this and he says what might have been in Lakhani's case, whether he could have ever gotten the missile, isn't even relevant.
问克里斯蒂这个问题，他说拉卡尼案件中可能发生的情况，也就是他是否真的能弄到导弹，根本不相关。
You're saying that he's a person who facilitates terrorist activity. But actually, he's a person who potentially might have facilitated. I mean, the fact is there actually wasn't a terrorist group, there wasn't a missile, he didn't do this deal. So is the question-- I guess you see him as someone who really would have been approached by a terrorist. I'm not sure where the evidence is for that. How do you make that argument, really? It seems like it's all speculation to say, he might have turned into a bad guy.
你是在说他是一个协助恐怖活动的人。但实际上，他是一个“可能潜在”协助的人。我的意思是，事实是他并没有一个恐怖组织，没有一枚导弹，他并没有完成这笔交易。所以问题是——我猜你把他看作一个真的会被恐怖分子接触的人。我不确定那证据在哪儿。你如何真正提出那个论点？说“他可能会变成一个坏蛋”，这听起来全是猜测。
No, I disagree with you. He was a bad guy. Once you find someone who is that, basically, amoral, then whether or not he was actually able to do it, that debate-- which I have one opinion of and the defense has another opinion of and maybe you have a slightly different opinion-- who cares? I mean, at the end, who cares? I don't have a crystal ball and I don't know, if this had fallen apart, what Hemant Lakhani would have done next. So the question is, confronted with those realities as American law enforcement, what we do? Do we ignore it because we say, maybe he could, maybe he couldn't? Let's see, let's see if he does.
不，我不同意你的观点。他就是个坏蛋。一旦你发现了一个本质上如此没有道德的人，那么他是否真的有能力去做这件事，那个争论——我有一个观点，辩方有另一个观点，也许你有稍微不同的观点——谁在乎呢？我的意思是，最后，谁在乎呢？我没有水晶球，我不知道如果这件事泡汤了，赫曼特·拉卡尼接下来会做什么。所以问题是，作为美国执法部门，面对这些现实，我们做什么？我们忽略它吗？因为我们说：“也许他能，也许他不能？”我们等着瞧，看他做不做。
I'm just not willing to take that chance, and I think most Americans would say the same thing. Hemant Lakhani was willing to sell missiles to a person he believed to be a terrorist, who expressly said he was going to use them to kill innocent people. And so there are good people and bad people. Bad people do bad things. Bad people have to be punished. These are simple truths. Bad people must be punished.
我只是不愿冒那个险，而且我认为大多数美国人会说同样的话。赫曼特·拉卡尼愿意将导弹卖给一个他认为是恐怖分子的人，而那个人明确表示要用导弹去杀害无辜的人。所以这世界上有好人也有坏人。坏人会做坏事。坏人必须受到惩罚。这是简单的真理。坏人必须受到惩罚。
And so, he's not just a guy with four beers in him at the corner bar who says, if I could get a missile and I'd sell it to whoever if I could make a buck, that's not who we're talking about here. So let's not minimize him either. He's not Osama bin Laden, but let's not make him Elmer Fudd either. All I know is that he's not the kind of guy I want coming through Newark Airport. He's not the kind of guy I want in this country. That's the kind of guy I want in federal prison, and so that's where he's going to go. And at the end, that's the success of the Lakhani case.
所以，他不仅仅是一个在街角酒吧里喝了四杯啤酒，说“如果我能弄到一枚导弹，只要能赚一笔，卖给谁都行”的家伙。我们要谈的不是这种人。所以也别把他最小化。他不是奥萨马·本·拉登，但也别把他弄成艾默·福德（Elmer Fudd）。我只知道他不是那种我想让他通过纽瓦克机场的人。他不是我想留在美国的人。他是我想送进联邦监狱的那种人，所以他会去那儿。最终，这就是拉卡尼案件的成功之处。
In Washington, the Lakhani case is seen as one of the most successful prosecutions in the War on Terror. It was one of three cases the Justice Department cited in testimony before Congress when the Patriot Act came up for renewal as an example of proactive, preemptive prosecution, which is basically designed to catch terrorists and the people who give them money and help before they actually do anything. Here's then-US Attorney General, John Ashcroft, giving a talk at the American Enterprise Institute a week after Lakhani's arrest. The title of his speech was "Securing Our Liberty: How America is Winning the War on Terror".
在华盛顿，拉卡尼案件被视为反恐战争中最成功的起诉之一。这是司法部在《爱国者法案》寻求续期时，在国会证词中引用的三个案件之一，作为“主动的、先发制人的起诉”的例子，其设计初衷本质上是为了在恐怖分子及其提供金钱和帮助的人采取行动之前将其抓获。这是时任美国司法部长约翰·阿什克罗夫特（John Ashcroft）在拉卡尼被捕一周后在企业研究所发表的演讲。他演讲的标题是《确保我们的自由：美国如何赢得反恐战争》。
Hemant Lakhani is an alleged arms dealer in Great Britain who is charged with attempting to sell shoulder-fired missiles to terrorists for use against American targets. The Lakhani investigation would not have been possible had American, Russian, and other foreign intelligence and law enforcement agencies not been able to coordinate and communicate the intelligence they had gained from various investigative tools.
赫曼特·拉卡尼是一名在英国的所谓军火商，被控试图向恐怖分子出售肩扛式导弹，用于攻击美国目标。如果美国、俄罗斯以及其他外国情报和执法机构不能协调和沟通他们从各种调查工具中获得的情报，拉卡尼调查就不可能实现。
But what's so hard to figure out is whether the government's methods are actually working. President Bush said recently that 400 people have been charged with terrorism-related crimes since the September 11 attacks, and that in over half of those cases, the defendants were convicted or pled guilty. But a recent investigation by the Washington Post , which spent six months examining almost every case, found that in reality, only 39 people, not 200, had been convicted of terrorism or national security-related crimes. And only 14 were connected to Al-Qaeda. Lakhani was counted as one of those 14.
但很难搞清楚的是，政府的方法是否真的有效。布什总统最近说，自9/11袭击以来，已有400人因恐怖主义相关罪行被起诉，在超过一半的案件中，被告被定罪或认罪。但《华盛顿邮报》最近的一项调查花了六个月时间审视了几乎每一个案件，发现实际上只有39人（而不是200人）因恐怖主义或国家安全相关罪行被定罪。而且只有14人与基地组织有关联。拉卡尼被算作那14人之一。
Most of the cases involve people who maybe were suspects in terrorism investigations. But when the evidence didn't pan out, they were charged with some low-level offense, like overstaying a visa, and given a short prison sentence or just deported. In other words, the Patriot Act is good at generating a lot of cases like the Lakhani case, turning up suspicious people who may or may not have anything to do with terrorism. To be fair, these are the leads the government has, so these are the leads they pursue. And for now, most people seem to be fine with that because they're scared. Even Donna, the juror, who knew the Lakhani missile sale was all a fake set up by the government was still terrified by it.
大多数案件涉及的人可能是恐怖主义调查中的嫌疑人。但当证据不足时，他们被指控犯有轻微罪行，比如签证逾期，并被判处短期监禁或直接驱逐出境。换句话说，《爱国者法案》擅长制造大量像拉卡尼案这样的案件，找出可能与恐怖主义有或没有关联的可疑人物。公平地说，这些是政府拥有的线索，所以这些是他们追求的线索。目前，大多数人似乎对这种情况感到满意，因为他们感到恐惧。即使是唐娜，那位知道拉卡尼导弹交易全是政府精心设置的骗局的陪审员，对此也感到恐惧。
Let's put it this way. I'm starting to look at colleges with my daughter. She's a junior in high school. I tell her, wherever we look, we're driving. I won't fly. Because now I realize how easy it is to take down a commercial airliner. You hear about suicide bombers and people that just don't care. Hopefully, my mind will change later on, but that box being wheeled into the courtroom is still too fresh in my mind. And you sit there and you think about innocent passengers losing their life and I won't fly.
这么说吧。我开始和女儿一起看大学了。她是高中三年级学生。我告诉她，无论我们看哪儿，我们都开车去。我不会坐飞机的。因为现在我意识到劫持一架商用客机是多么容易。你会听到自杀式炸弹袭击者和那些根本不在乎的人。希望我的想法以后会改变，但那个被推进法庭的箱子在我脑海中依然太清晰了。你坐在那里，想着无辜的乘客失去生命，我不会坐飞机的。
So has the Lakhani case make you feel more secure or more afraid?
那么拉卡尼案件让你感到更安全还是更恐惧？
In some respects, it makes me feel more afraid because now I'm really aware of people out there that try to do harm. I feel secure with the FBI looking out for us, but unfortunately they're not going to be able to stop every terrorist or every accomplice trying to help terrorism.
在某些方面，它让我感到更恐惧，因为现在我真正意识到外面有试图造成伤害的人。我觉得FBI在照看我们是安全的，但不幸的是，他们无法阻止每一个恐怖分子或每一个试图帮助恐怖主义的同谋。
That's the thing about the Lakhani case. Knowing its whole history makes you feel simultaneously comforted and afraid.
这就是拉卡尼案件的特点。了解它的整个过程会让你感到既受安慰又感到恐惧。
Hemant Lakhani will be sentenced this summer. He's 70, there's a good chance he'll spend the rest of his life in prison. Petra Bartosiewicz is a reporter in New York City.
赫曼特·拉卡尼将于今年夏天宣判。他已经70岁了，他很有可能在监狱里度过余生。佩特拉·巴托谢维奇是纽约市的一名记者。
Our program is produced by Sarah Koenig and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Diane Cook, Jane Feltes, and Lisa Pollak. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder, Elizabeth Meister runs our website. Production help from Todd Bachmann and Laura Bellows.
我们的节目由莎拉·科尼格和我本人制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）、黛安·库克（Diane Cook）、简·费尔特斯（Jane Feltes）和莉萨·波拉克（Lisa Pollak）参与。我们的资深制片人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder），伊丽莎白·迈斯特（Elizabeth Meister）负责运营我们的网站。制作帮助来自托德·巴赫曼（Todd Bachmann）和劳拉·贝洛斯（Laura Bellows）。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[感谢名单]
Our website, www.thisamericanlife.org. You know, you can download today's program in our archives at audible.com/thisamericanlife. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
我们的网站是www.thisamericanlife.org。你知道，你可以在audible.com/thisamericanlife的存档中下载今天的节目。《这美国生活》由公共广播国际公司发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight for our program by Mr. Torey Malatia, who usually calls me by one of these names:
WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生负责，他通常用以下名字之一称呼我：
Meal ticket, dupe, patsy.
饭票、傻瓜、替罪羊。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《这美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际公司。